April the 15th 2013 two bombs task through the crowd,
welcoming runners over the finish line at the Boston marathon.
The carnage is total with three people killed and dozens.
We ended within hours.
The FBI have identified a pair of suspects,
the two brothers,
a immigrants to America whose parents had fled the violence of Chechnya to give
their children a better life.
So how did it all go?
So wrong today through the story of the younger of the two brothers Joey Asana
have we find out
yoga and Zora Vich.
Sonia was born on July the 22nd 1993 in Kyrgyzstan,
has parents who are Amazon and Zuber.
Dot.
Sanjiv and saw what was a cattle farm labor in the Caspian region of Kalmykia
and Zubeidat was the city girl who'd struggled to fit in to the railroad
community life that marriage gave up.
His spirits were lifted with the birth of her first child in October of 1986 the
couple of names,
the boy time alone to the great Asian conquer up Zubid arms was a doting mother.
She always dressed Tom Elaine,
who was nicknamed Tommy in the best attire.
The boy did well in school.
His mother put pressure on her husband to move in order to provide the best son
with wider opportunities,
their returns,
Ansell's hometown and moved in with his parents.
About a year later rounds us father.
He was killed in a working accidents.
This left him as the family patriarch with the collapse of the Soviet Union life
in the region.
It changed dramatically.
Labor became entrepreneurs overnight.
As the Western economies began flooding in and found a job as a car repairman.
He was making a living,
but in order to really get ahead,
he realized that he had to move to the newly created republic of Chechnya,
which seems like the new promised land.
The family,
which now included two daughters,
moved to Chechnya in 1992 it was there that the second son Jogo was born.
He was named after the charismatic president of Chechnya.
Jugaad duty of within just a year though,
things had gone horribly wrong.
The Russians invaded Chechnya and the Sony has found themselves in the middle of
a war zone.
The family,
Paul into a battle of old [inaudible] drive back to Kurgestan and the old family
home and talk mock.
They settled back into their old lives while also be making plans to get out of
eastern Europe.
Their goal,
well that was America and Zoran Zuber Darts believed that their chances of
getting to America would be improved if they obtained some educational
credentials.
As a result,
they both began studying your part time after four years and talk mark and they
sold the family home and moved not to America,
but [inaudible] hometown of Dagestan.
However,
it seemed as if his family where I've done able to escape from Warren's before
along the streets were filled with gunfights and explosions.
The they have family moved once again [inaudible] yoga with them on a trip to
the United States time alone.
The along with the two daughters was left with their own goal in Kyrgyzstan.
They traveled on a 90 day tourist visa during that visit ends or applied
political asylum,
claiming that his life was in danger due to his connections with Chechnya.
The application was submitted in the family were allowed to stay in a decision
was reached.
The Sani of said chosen to come to Boston,
Massachusetts.
That was web.
Some friends had moved to previous year,
so at least they would know somebody.
They moved in with this couple and the eight year old gighub again,
attending second grade at a public school along with the tube.
You have children in April of 2002 and sort of managed to find an inexpensive
apartment in Cambridge,
Massachusetts and they moved out of the BF home and into their own place.
Droga was left with a the for the meantime in order to not interrupt his school.
Yeah,
and Zora and exhibit hours presented themselves as prospective lawyers even
though their studies had been minimal.
When people lost,
they told them that they were fleeing from ethnic strife.
They found a kindred spirit in their landlord,
Johanna,
her,
he who took them under her wing.
She took z arts too and Amnesty International events focused on human rights
abuses in Chechnya and even paid for her to enrolled in a Harvard extension
course on negotiation and Zar picks off under the table jobs fixing cars for $10
an hour.
When the school year was over,
Juggalo came to live with his parents and Cambridge.
His time with a B.
Abs had been challenging.
His parents insisted that the only language spoken in the home was Chechen,
which he could barely understand when the parents weren't around.
The children would speak Russian.
He learned English from his association with American Kids at school picking
your town,
but at an amazing pace.
Jirga became an accepted member of the church and Community of children in the
local area.
He was a good students.
He made quick advancements.
In fact,
during his second year at school,
he was bumped up from the third grade to the fourth in mid 2003 the Siana,
his asylum application.
It was granted the three children left Kurgestan and we are now free to join the
family and the promised lands with the family.
Ray United.
Things were looking pretty good for the immigrant family,
both on Zuora and Zubid Artois working and they had permanence and affordable
accommodation.
Wow.
Joe Guh is remembered as a sweet,
lovable boy.
He was described as being charming.
His teachers described him as being Bryce,
but lacking in the ability to think creatively for himself.
He tended to see things that got other people to like him.
In 2003 a Juggalo and did the fifth grade.
His sister's 13 year olds leaner and 15 year old Barolo were in seventh and
ninth grades.
17 year old.
Tom Allen was in 10th grade.
The landlady,
Joanna tutored the children in English and took them to movies and let them
watch DVDs.
Tom Allen now augmented his studies with Joanna by reading Sherlock Holmes
stories.
Being the oldest son,
Tom Milan,
was the focus of the families' plans for success.
He was the golden haired child,
the one who was destined for greatness.
He was tall,
muscular,
and handsome.
Even the Americans saw something special in him.
Anzel decided that before heading off to college,
his oldest son would become a champion boxer,
tamarind and proved himself to be a gifted fighter.
Yet a very unconventional stance with his arms hanging down rather than in a
defensive stance after training with his for a while and he turns up at a local
martial arts gym.
Yup.
No malfeasance helmets or other protective gear and his claims that he didn't
need them.
When are you going into the ring?
He proved it.
His stage and admission was to win a spot on the U S and Olympic team and to use
that position as a way of becoming a naturalized US citizen.
Thailand's first victory in a boxing competition was achieved in January of 2004
it was a golden gloves homage bout had in lowel,
Massachusetts and his post to victory interview.
He said,
I like the USA.
You have a chance to make some money here if you are willing to work.
In 2006 ton.
Elon was enrolled at Bunker Hill community college for two years.
He focused on his studies.
Then in 2009 and he returned to boxing.
We then a year he had made it onto the national amateur boxing circuits.
In 2010 he won the rocky Marciano trophy for winning the New England golden
gloves competition,
but because he wasn't a US citizen,
he was ineligible to fight for the national title.
This was a severe blow to Tom Landon's.
It caused him to just give up on his boxing career.
By that time,
Tom Atlanta also dropped out of college.
His focus was now on becoming a music stop.
He began dressing flamboyantly with one person describing as looks is that of an
Italian Gigolo.
While American teenage boys might have marked as looks,
the girls were in Trump stunts.
He had no shortage of female admires and 2011 Tamela and the great hope of that
son.
Our family was a failed to boxer,
a college dropout,
and a father.
He was still living at home with his parents,
but his girlfriends and child when not for money,
he delivered pizzas parttime and sold marijuana on the site.
It was not exactly the career path that his parents had had in mind despite
their initial efforts to integrate into American society.
By 2011 that sign Sinovis had given up on trying.
After struggling with the language,
with the culture and even with buying things on credit,
they reverted back to what they were comfortable with.
They decided to live as Chechens transplanted their home at the typical Czechian
look,
oriental rugs,
a large plush surface and a mirrored Credenza,
housing plates.
Things had not planned out like they envisioned their neighbors.
They viewed them with suspicion if not with outright hostility.
There son was dealing drugs,
both their daughters and entered into disastrous marriages and Enzo was spending
his days fixing old cars in the street.
In mid 2011 Jogi graduated from Rindge college and moved to the University of
Massachusetts at Dartmouth where he lived on campus.
A couple of months later.
His parents,
they filed for divorce by now.
All of the rest of his family had become disillusioned with their life in
America,
but not Jakafi.
He continued to make good grades and establish a solid and positive friendships.
He maintained his friendly,
happy outlook,
had called edge.
He joined the wrestling team.
He impressed as coaches with his humility and constant requests,
what he could do to improve.
It was a marked contrast to the American boys on the team who did not do this
before long.
He was the captain of the wrestling team just like his older brother.
However,
Chagall was smoking and also selling dope.
Yes,
his image of the pure sweet teenage boy.
It was so complete that no one had any inkling that this was the case.
Droga develops a friendship with one of the colleges,
most respected professors.
Larry Aronson was the college's official photographer,
Aronson adults,
a jirga as the poster child for kids from war torn zone and see what now
attending Rindge college.
He also helped the boy come up with a more American friendly version of his
name.
Josh Aronson was interested in engaging Jaeger and discussions about what was
going on in Chechnya,
but the teenager had no desire to talk about is old country.
Aronson said,
whenever I tried to talk to him about being Chechen,
it meant nothing to him.
Meanwhile,
Joe,
his older brother,
Tamerlan,
was moving in the other direction.
In January of 2012 he flew to Dagestan.
He went to his old hometown of Maca color.
This was the carbs.
I love Dagestan nuns.
Over the last 10 years,
it has transformed into a modern city Tamela and quickly fit into the social
scene,
spending his days mixing with forever and young men in their twenties and
thirties who talked about their religion,
their aspirations,
and the injustices in the world.
He met any of his relatives,
a number of whom were involved in organized crime.
Some of them joins a group called the Union of the just which was allied to the
his boots [inaudible] one of the largest Islamic organizations in the world.
He's told members of the group there's America was a racist country that was
deeply divided with corrupt police and does Zena phobic foreign policy.
When asked to compare America with Russia,
Tomberlin is reported to have said,
I refuse to choose between two kinds of fecal matter.
Both tastes like Shit and 2012 Tomlin's hold his associates that he urgently
needed to return to the United States because he had a problem with his
documentation.
He ends up meeting that he had no desire to go back and he would return soon.
Tomberlin returned to Cambridge to discover that his father had himself returned
to Dagestan and had started a successful car repair business with his brother.
A couple of weeks later,
zipit dot also returned to Dagestan.
Not to reunite with her ex husband's,
but to live with her own family.
To Tom Mullen Dagestan it was now home.
He would only stand the u s long enough to get his passport.
Jonah,
hello.
He's the landlord had become increasingly concerned with the radicalization of
the family.
After a,
he didn't council with Tom Alon in which he vented about his hatred of America.
She issued them an eviction notice
back at college.
John got a new roommate.
Andrew Dwindles was a young American go getter.
The engineering major was going places and there's a very presence highlighted
to jihad.
Just how inadequate he really was.
The two never spoken,
only exchanged messages when one of them was locked out of the room.
Shahar had a small and tight knit group of friends.
All of them being eastern European.
There was also a steady flow of customers to his dorm room in order to buy pot.
Within a few months,
your whole social circle had widened slightly to include a couple of Americans.
They congregated off campus at the apartments,
have a couple of members of the group once jar disclose to a couple of members
of that group the tenure to make a bomb.
He also said that there were parts of the Quran that will worth fighting for
with force is still,
he was not a Muslim extremist though.
Those in his group who had met his brother,
considered Tom Alon to be one
Patriot's day,
2013 a casual on April the 15th it's a public holiday in Massachusetts and it's
the day that the Boston marathon is run two hours after the start of the
marathon at 2:49 PM there's runners with streaming across the finish line.
Two bombs exploded near the end of the course.
Three people were killed and 264 others were wounded in the immediate aftermath
of the bombing,
the police scan the crowd in an attempt to identify anyone who looked out of
place.
The first target was a Saudi Arabian man who had actually been wounded in the
blog posts.
He was quickly cleared and then three other Muslim men were looked at,
but all were dismissed.
On Thursday,
April the 18th the Boston post published a photo when it's from page with a band
of that red bag.
Then fed seek these two pictures of Boston marathon.
The two men were Tom Mullen and do your hot sauna have when Larry runs and
picked up the pay,
but he thought that one of the men looked amazingly like jihad.
Then when students at the university,
so the picture,
they didn't think that it looks like Jihad and they were convinced that it was
him.
Still.
His friends couldn't believe that he had been involved in the bombing.
He just didn't seem capable of such a thing.
Rather than going to the police or the FBI,
his friends went to jaws dorm,
but the door was locked,
unable to locate Shahar.
His friends went back to their dorm and proceeded to play Xbox a short time.
NASA,
one of them received a text and jaw that reds,
if you want,
you can go to my room and take.
What's that?
They were tends in the ream used to Spanky to get in and began to such his side
of the room.
One of them found a black backpack that contained a launch metal cylinder off an
empty jar of Vaseline.
He turned to his friends and said,
I think he used these to make the bomb.
The FBI had been focused on Jihad as early as Wednesday morning.
They had been studying video of the aftermath of the explosions and it was
noticed that Jihad didn't react to the blast.
While everyone else ran duct and screams,
he just kept right on walking.
They also noticed tunnel and walking alongside showing no sign of reaction,
but the problem was they had no idea where these men were,
the images they were issued to the American public with a warning that they were
considered to be armed and extremely dangerous in the hours following the
bombing.
Local media blames the path of every crime committed in the area,
including the murder of an MIT police officer.
They've got that last accusation,
right?
The brothers killed officer Shaun Collier in order to steal his gun.
They then committed to car jacking into Cambridge gas station.
They were driving a Mercedes SUV,
but they were unaware that it was fitted with a gps device.
This allowed the police to track their every movement.
They seem to be driving around aimlessly,
which they were because they had no plan of action post bombing in their
possession.
The brothers had five homemade explosive devices,
a semiautomatic handgun,
a machete and a hunting knife
they he was doing on the brothers in a quiet suburban in the suburb of Watertown
and began randomly firing.
One of the offices was seriously wounded by friendly fire.
The brothers were the Helene to cover ans when ordered to give up Shahar through
the explosive devices towards the cops.
They exploded harmlessly on the street.
The final shootout was between Tamma Landon's,
Watertown police officer named Jed prerelease.
The officer scored several body heads swell.
Thailand failed to find his targets.
When his ammunition ran out,
he threw his gun at the officer.
He then decided to flee and the officer's chased him.
They see him go to him and dragged him to the ground,
but now jihad jumps behind the wheel of the SUV and proceeded to run down the
offices.
They quickly jumped aside and on.
Wizardly ran over the top of his brother dragging the body 30 feet down the
street,
leaving his brother dying on the road to hoe sped away.
It took nearly a minute for the police to give chase.
By then ditched the car,
runs run off into the suburbs,
but the police offices,
they scoured backyards in dozens of suburbs and thousands of people were ordered
to evacuate the homes.
Uh,
Watertown homeowner reported seeing blood on the side of a boat in his yard.
I Swat team rush to the house.
Joe had been hiding in the cupboard boat for hours.
The officers attempted to coax him out with tear gas and that failed.
They fired bullets to scare him out in the ends and imposing officer approached
the boat and demanded that he come out immediate beat.
A childish voice replied,
but it's going to hurt.
Police officers then moved in and help jihad make his way down from the boat.
He was severely wounded with either bullet or shrapnel injuries to the neck.
Aaron fi he was rushed to hospital where he was operated on.
According to one of his nurses,
he cried out for two days straight after his operation.
When the police search the inside of the boat that had been jaws final hideouts,
they found the following message written in blood.
The bombings were in retribution for the u s crimes in places like Iraq and
Afghanistan that the victims of the Boston bombing were collateral damage.
In the same way innocent victims have been collateral damage in us wars around
the world.
John's trial began on January the fifth 2015 he was charged with four counts of
murder along with 26 of the challenges.
The prosecution,
they sought the death penalty even though Massachusetts that outlawed the death
penalty in 1988 the federal charges made it possible he pled not guilty to all
of the charges.
The defense position was that Tom alone had been the mastermind of the
enterprise into this.
Joe Hall had been coerced into cooperating.
It's on if showed no emotion throughout the trial until his family members took
the stance.
That point he wept.
On April the eighth 2015 jihad was found guilty on old 30 charges among Fenay
said he was sentenced to death by lethal injection.
He now sits in the notorious supermax prison,
Adx Florence in Fremont County called Colorado.
Meanwhile,
his defense team of working on an appeal to his death sentence.
So have you found that video?
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and do not forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos like this several times a week.
If you don't get to something else right now,
they why not check out my other channel called top tens you'll find a link to
that in the description below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.